in offshoot of George Romero's Living
Dead films this spiritual cousin is
easily one of the most goofy enjoyable
zombie movies ever 1985's Return of the
Living Dead follows a group of dirt bag
ravers whose graveyard party gets upset
by a zombie uprising caused by acid rain
return takes a lively approach to its
material that still feels fresh even if
the hilariously dated fashion of the
characters decidedly does not why do you
eat people not people
brains being too self ious about zombie
material is a trap that lots of movies
fellows fall into but return sidesteps
that problem with a plum it's not a
parody just a great ride